and i'm getting an update that there's
something very drastic happen in the
hikaru game peter
can we just jump to that for just a
moment
yeah bishop d5 played okay if it drastic
it means that the opponent game is
which seems to be perfectly fine for
black
is lost yeah look d7 because then
you can take and the king comes and it's
in time
very hard to believe but
so what you're saying is that after yeah
first he he first he waits you have it
luke the eighth
and black can't go rook d1 bishop b3
because you trade and you go a6 a7 and
there's no way to fight that from
queening and that's hikaru nakamura
shaking his head
uh maybe we'll maybe just quickly we'll
take a look at what went wrong
everything was under control but
something collapsed but let's take a
look
i mean sorry you know it's not the point
the point is that he plays
a6 and after cc he can already take
everything because then
he queens with the check yes so the
eighth was probably missed by hikaru he
simply judged that luke d7 is not
dangerous because in the opponent game
he is exactly in time
and in fact it would be bad for white
but this rook d8 and
suddenly he just almost feels like he
wins on the spot yeah
takes d5 so actually peter bishop d5 was
a big blunder his bishop was on c4
keeping the a6
square under control and bishop d5 just
loses on the spot and hikaru just gets
up he's resigned
yes because rook d5 like you pointed out
white queens with a check